oh no has it been a year already You're
a Grand Old Flag you're a high-flying
flag I'm forever in peace my way
we love the 4th of July it's the perfect
holiday you get to cook outside blow
stuff up wear shorts Easter should be
taking notes
[Music]
that was longer than I remember
hello Joe you should be thankful that
you live in this country I spent half of
my childhood in a Banana Republic it was
the only store in my Village that had
air conditioner yes Mr President
yes sir I'd be honored to sir thank you
amazing news the Grand Marshal for
today's parade just got me too and they
need me to fill in
Jay I'm so happy for you so now the only
thing left in your bucket list is to
Bear knuckle fighter Russian oh and
Manny is gonna be back home from his big
road trip just in time for the parade
he's gone for so long I can't wait to
see him that's great we'll have the
whole family back together with me to
ride in the convertible of Baron Joe has
your parade wave
we'll work on it every heart beats
through
[Music]
that's the biggest one they got yes and
I'm not going back again
have you seen Manny I've been looking
all over him I don't see him I've been
here busy inspecting the troops young
lady could you straighten that hat sir
that that horn could use a shine haircut
Gloria if this goes well in a couple of
months I'll be lighting the town
Christmas tree take that dad you know
what is weird after so many years to be
at a parade with people fully dressed oh
yeah Focus you've got a big role in this
after I cut the ribbon it's your job to
fire off the cannon that's the signal
for everybody to start marching it isn't
the grand Marshal's job to fire the
cannon so the ribbon Cuts itself Gloria
which you don't know about parade
Bobby hello
are you coming the parade is about to
start hey Jay
hey Tom how's it going great actually my
wife and I were back together well not
exactly I mean we're going on dates
we're hoping to recap yeah I want to
hear all about it but I think the local
paper needs a photo oh oh of course yeah
Gloria get in the shot
Gloria but you promised you were going
to be here just shoot no go ahead shoot
it what okay
[Music]
Jim and Corey has been cutting these
aren't lefties
Grand Marshall take that Grandpa you
must be on top of the world well I'm
putting on a brave face from the good of
the country but the truth is we did not
get off to a great start Gloria is not
on her game today and I'm afraid she's
going to forget to leave the standing
ovation after my speech
tagging you in your cue is Pursuit of
Happiness and if you can sell it to
Bravo would be nice okay I I know what's
wrong with Gloria this is a big day for
you and she's feeling left out no that's
not it damn it you're not getting here
till tomorrow how does your name even
have the word man in it something just
clicked draw trouble no she was just on
with Manny who's not coming don't Gloria
and Manny have some Fourth of July
tradition come to think of it they share
a slice of apple pie and watch the
fireworks they've been doing that every
year since he was born until this year
which is why Gloria is upset you're
right I let the sash go to my head I
never should have brought it oh I can
help you out but you're gonna have to
give up on your little speech thing Hey
kid whoa where'd you get the fireworks
you a cop there's a stand in the grocery
store parking lot but he's closing up
you get the fireworks and the apple pie
I will take care of Manny I am back I am
really bad my car's blocked in all this
traffic I'll never make it look at that
right there
check it out I was Rider cool listen I
need to borrow your car it's kind of an
emergency but my dad's excited to see me
in the parade he was a Tuskegee Airman
maybe the minute you stopped trying so
hard is the minute he'll start Loving
You Now hop out of there and go clear a
path to me through those lawn chairs
come on I'll help you out
okay
how was the parade I had something more
important to do I got a few weird looks
at the drive through but it was worth it
to help keep your tradition alive you
mean Manny and me it's not gonna happen
I got that covered too
hi Mom
hi Mom should we really get the
dangerous job to my only smart one
of July Bobby I'll be home soon before
you know it Thomas Jefferson it was sort
of the Grand Marshal of his time believe
this country should be a place where
people are free to pursue happiness and
a better life
where we can set our sights on the Stars
and with hard work and determination
make the impossible a reality because
Americans don't run from challenges we
embrace them
God Bless America
hold for Applause
that would have killed right
you know I gave up a lot today you could
mean it
[Music]